[Música]
en directo a Vamos hasta Washington con
nuestro corresponsal Cristóbal Vázquez
quien tiene información sobre el
dictamen que obliga al ex vicepresidente
Mike pence a testificar en la
declaración sobre el asalto al Capitolio
del 6 de enero de 2021 Cristóbal muy
buenas noches cuéntenos Qué dijo el juez
que tomó esta decisión
Pues es que Mike pence y Donald Trump
tuvieron una llamada el 5 de enero del
2021 día antes de la toma al Capitolio y
en esta llamada el expresidente le decía
a Mike pence que desconociera los
resultados electorales en este proceso
que era simplemente un proceso de
costumbre un proceso legal en el
congreso para reconocer los votos
electorales sin embargo
se negaba y en las llamadas que hay se
alcanza a pues grabar y a constatar que
precisamente pence se negó varias veces
a esto por eso el expresidente pues lo
llamó según medios Nacionales con
bastante insultos precisamente por no
querer llevar a cabo este
desconocimiento electoral entonces lo
que le está pidiendo el juez del
distrito de Columbia Alexia el
vicepresidente es que testifique sobre
Esa llamada pero no necesariamente sobre
lo que ocurrió el 6 de enero de hecho el
ex vicepresidente tiene la opción de
apelar esta decisión y el equipo legal
del ex vicepresidente está en este
momento considerando que va a ser frente
a esta decisión se apelará o si
efectivamente pues eh llevará a cabo
esta audiencia con el gran Jurado del
distrito de Colombia Cristóbal a
propósito de otro gran tema judicial que
se mueve ahí en Estados Unidos que se
sabe sobre la investigación sobre el
presunto pago por parte de Trump con
dineros de la campaña de 2016 a una
actriz porno a cambio de su silencio
Cómo va ese proceso
pues bastante enredado recordemos que el
expresidente Donald Trump había dicho en
sus redes sociales que incluso iba a ser
arrestado esposado en Nueva York después
de que en la gran Jurado lo le hiciera
la acusación formal de haber usado plata
de campaña para callar a esta actriz
porno con los que supuestamente había
tenido un romance se esperaba que la
semana pasada ya hubiera una acusación
formal por parte de este gran Jurado
pero la decisión empezó a aplazarse
aplazarse aplazarse y pues este es el
día que no sabemos Cuándo va a ser esta
audiencia finalmente
algunos analistas decían que iba a ser
el miércoles de esta semana pero pues no
hay Claridad al respecto y parece que
tampoco va a ser el jueves Así que
tendrá que aplazarse una semana más lo
que muchos analistas están diciendo
analistas demócratas es que una decisión
de este nivel no al presidente Joe biden
porque pues pone como víctima a el
expresidente Donald Trump y le da un
capital político bastante alto Así que
hay bastante incertidumbre sobre el
futuro de esta decisión que recordemos
pues el equipo legal de Donald Trump
rechaza completamente la acusación que
supuestamente vendría por parte de este
gran Jurado de que usó plata de campaña
de el 2016 para pagar el silencio de la
actriz porno extraordinario